Wars Battlefront gameplay Dan shut the
[ __ ] up
hey guys I'm Ryan right I'm Dan cyber
I'm smiling today cuz we're gonna watch
Star Wars Battlefront gameplay launch
trailer gameplay Ron's trailer how much
launch launch launch like you're
watching
it's the stache it is unavoidable we
will witness the destruction of the
Alliance that's a phrase Jeremy oh no
wicked rebellion soldiers from the Rebel
Alliance first you're almost guys first
did in there
right focus your attack on the Walker
nice
Wow
that won't happen again remember mental
walkers from reaching the stretch
scary talking about
or the wall here we go
yeah a physic rebellion yeah there's a
[ __ ] ever
dude I'm so [ __ ] pumped this is I
think my favorite trailer so far I gotta
play this game right if you do a
gameplay of it you gotta bring me on oh
yeah for sure man dude if you've ever
wanted to be a part of the battle world
of Star Wars this is it it feels like
the adventure of Star Wars all the great
bad like Darth Vader was [ __ ] scared
dude I was a little [ __ ] yeah now this
guy's so fancies intimidating I'd be
scared because of all the [ __ ] about
Darth Vader already it's like you're so
messed it in the story of Darth Vader
that you're like I would not [ __ ] with
Darth Vader just the way that you just
kind of walks in just throws his
lightsaber grabs it back and just start
to room all those dudes yeah yeah yeah
Wow I play as han Solo
yeah [ __ ] yeah I want to play as home so
mmm I wish a calf plays Chewie probably
camp for Jar Jar there's elk you get it
this is a funny man you've ever seen a
comedian you should look again so I mean
one of the things coming from the beta
one of the major criticisms right now
and I think it kind of came especially
with the trailers coming out too as a
lot of people are saying it feels just
like battlefield and I'm like I think we
just this another trailer but like yeah
it's I mean it's made from the same guys
it's the dice engine I'm gonna [ __ ]
there's nothing wrong with that no there
is it so it's similar in some ways I
don't give a [ __ ]
it's cool that you're blending the
battlefield gameplay style with Star
Wars yeah as long as the game launches
and it isn't like the battlefield 4
fiasco where it was just foggy as all
hell then yeah sure I'm totally given
bite on day one however for me I might
wait just a little bit for like another
patch to come out this looks awesome it
does it looks so good it's amazing it
looks genuinely amazing as a movie fan
I'm like I gotta play this game because
this is like a chance to be a part of
the arm like the stormtroopers armor
looks so good I'm totally [ __ ] them I
mean I was down I was always down with
its game han solo looks sexy in this you
know what here's support today still a
sexy grey [ __ ]
mm-hmm that's packed we both fantasizing
about him right now
are you are you having sex with Harrison
Ford in your mind I was getting a beer
with them you why did dying
Harrison Ford my anyway guys enough gay
jokes today if you're new to the channel
subscribe today by clicking this button
above my head well become a reject a bot
it's creepier with my stash and yeah you
can check out Dan's gaming channel where
he does gaming plays on there and you
could follow us on social medias [ __ ]
Instagram and Vine I've been told to
promote that promote from my
representation Instagram vine easiest
way for me to become more successful
many followers there and I'll provide
decent content oh how kind of you
yeah decent did people will post a photo
on Instagram yeah 20 grand right there
off of a photo on Instagram I only got
like a little over 5,000 followers on
Instagram people do you really don't
mind whoa you give me more more I post
my post we put a really good one not
you're gonna stick around yeah over at
my place is really good it was funny why
don't you like us no I happened well
they like you Oh what it's the mustache
stache I'm gonna get so many [ __ ]
like what is on Dan's face the pet the
pedo comments are gonna be real Alyssa
says Tom Selleck no that's a very small
moustache pervert awesome